hi there i'll put on my non-reflecting
glasses as i normally do here now let's
get down to pimsleur
um
i discussed pimsleur oh my blue snowball
again
i just discussed pimsleur uh
the uh sort of very kind of snake oil
salesman approach they had to sell in
their product someone pointed out that
they all the different companies do this
and of course that's true
and i looked at some of the books that i
have and
as you can see like that's only a small
number of the books that i have but they
all promise
you know if i grab any one of them here
teach yourself
learn to speak this is their beginner
book
you can't really see me here this is
their beginner book and this is quite
typical of all of them
they promise you know learn to speak
understand and write russian progress
quickly beyond the basics explore the
language in depth
none of this is true you only really get
started with this book and there are
other books like that hugo i have
and others and they promise that what is
this hugo's check here i had this
kicking around from before in three
months check in three months
uh
blah blah blah
this is a little doesn't quite promise
you
um
you know it just says you'll learn it
fast that's fair enough but the point is
you in fact learn very little they say
in each chapter you know in this chapter
you will learn to master the subjunctive
or you will learn to master this other
thing in fact you don't because the
process of learning the language is such
a gradual process and when these
different concepts and vocabulary items
kick in is anybody's guess has been my
experience it certainly doesn't happen
on cue after 10 days or three months or
anything like that
but getting back to pimsleur
um
you know
the thing about language learning to me
is that it takes a long time
uh if i look at you know
i was just looking at for example i've
been at czech now i figure
uh with my travels to china and
elsewhere and that i think you probably
spent over 100 hours on it
now after 100 hours i can uh i can read
a fair number of
newspaper articles
uh i'll typically import them into links
so that i can look up words that i don't
know but i know enough words to
basically pick my way through them even
without link i am reading that history
book of mine where i basically don't
bother looking up words because it's too
much trouble and i can understand the
meaning and it's very interesting so i'm
reading an adult level book in czech
after 100 hours
if i had used pimsleur i wouldn't be
doing that now it's possible that i
would be speaking more
on a limited range of things but i can't
see myself spending hundreds of hours
like i took out my pimsleur russian and
there's a you know sort of a simple
dialogue there uh
and there's like eight cds and it never
gets past this idea of
this guy trying to invite this girl for
a drink
and um there's no text to read and the
words that repeat are are some of the
things that in many cases are difficult
to remember like numbers like i never
worry about numbers because i know that
numbers are going to take me a long long
time and it really doesn't matter
um
so that uh you know it's it's a
tremendously for me time-consuming way
of
acquiring vocabulary and for me the big
thing in learning languages is acquiring
vocabulary because i want to understand
i want to understand what i read i want
to understand what i hear
so i'm close to understanding the czech
radio now when i listen to it it helps
if i know the subject it obviously helps
a lot if and i'll if the subject is you
know the dispute in the czech cabinet
over the restitution of church lands or
something that there have been four or
five different articles on if i hear
something about it i understand what
they're talking about very well if it's
a new subject that i'm not very
interested in it's a lot more difficult
but still i feel that my hundred hours
invested in check are
that's a good return because i can
listen and read to a fair you know to an
extent the other thing i don't like
about pimsleur
is one of my objections to traditional
language teaching is that the teacher or
in the case of pimsleur decides what
you're going to learn they decide which
phrases are important to you
i prefer to pick the words and phrases
that i want also pimsleur puts you on
the spot they force you to respond they
force you to say something now i don't
want to do that uh i'm quite happy i'm
like but i i should say right off the
off the bat that a lot of people love
pimpster so it's very much a matter of
what you like to do and because language
learning takes so much time like i was
calculating that in russian over the
last five years i've probably spent 1500
hours with the russian language
listening reading or reviewing words or
whatever i've been doing speaking
at least 1500 hours maybe closer to 2000
hours i i couldn't spend that time doing
stuff that i found uninteresting so i
find pimsleur uninteresting the content
is uninteresting being forced to say
things are not is uninteresting them
deciding what i'm supposed to say and
when i don't like doing so i prefer
doing things that i enjoy because i have
to spend so much time doing it with
chinese
it didn't take me
five years it took me 10 months
essentially 9 or 10 months but i was
working 7 to 10 hours a day so i was
getting i mean i had over 3000 hours of
input to the chinese but that was again
reading speaking listening the things
that i like to do so i'm prepared to put
the time in doing it
if it's some kind of a brain dead you
know bark now kind of thing i i don't
think i'd keep at it
so
my big thing with with pimsleur is that
it gets for some people to get some
started i don't need it need it to get
me started but i don't think i'd spend a
lot of time at it but
i i accept that other people do and
other people enjoy it
so um yeah that's the thing i think uh
to some extent as long as we're able to
spend time with the language to some
extent it really doesn't matter
what we do
and what perhaps is more important is
what our goals are and what we like to
do and that will determine the kind of
language learning activity that is
effective for us thank you for listening